hier springen die besten free ski aus
Chinas
[Musik]
wir sind in nanschan eine Stunde
nordöstlich von Peking und verabredet
mit einem den alle den anzug-
seit zehn Jahren fährt er Freestyle und
wenn nicht gerade im Wettbewerb wie
heute fliegt er im Anzug über die
Schanze
ich liebe es diesen Jumper zu fliegen
durch die Luft wie ein Vogel ich liebe
das Gefühl der Freiheit
sie fahren auf 100% Kunstschnee echten
Schnee gibt es in der Region um Peking
nur selten im siebten Jahr findet der
Wettbewerb in diesem Skigebiet statt
nachdem er vergangenes Jahr wegen Corona
ausfiel dort liefern war immer dabei
heute ist er zum ersten Mal nicht im
Finale seine Sprünge sind nicht ganz so
spektakulär weil er sich vor ein paar
Tagen am Knie verletzt hat
er gehört zu den Skifahrern der ersten
Stunde
2004 bin ich zum ersten Mal Ski gefahren
da fingen die ersten an Ski zu fahren
auch beim Freestyle war eher ganz früh
dabei die Branche wächst zwar ist aber
immer noch so klein dass sich alle
kennen
viele meiner Skifreunde haben aus ihrem
Hobby einen Beruf gemacht ich bin
wahrscheinlich der einzige der nicht in
der Branche arbeitet sie wollten mehr
Zeit auf der Piste haben und fanden Jobs
in skiläden oder haben selbst eine
eröffnet
einen dieser Freunde wollen wir treffen
und machen uns auf den Weg zu den
olympischen Wettkampfstätten im
Nordwesten Pekings
vor einem Jahr fanden die Spiele statt
was ist davon übrig von der staatlich
verordneten wintersportbegeisterung und
von den Spielen selbst die
lautveranstalter besonders nachhaltig
und umweltfreundlich waren
die Autobahn ist wohl das sichtbarste
Überbleibsel
der Rastplatz hier das war der Eingang
in den olympischen Bereich hier wurden
die Sportlerinnen und Sportler direkt
vom Flughafen kommend auf Corona
getestet die Straße und alles hier
rundum wurde extra für Olympia gebaut
heute knapp ein Jahr später sind wir
ziemlich alleine hier
ein paar Kilometer weiter sehen wir die
spektakuläre Olympia Bobbahn die erste
Chinas der Drache von yanching
schlängelt sich fast zwei Kilometer
durch den Berg diese Tagesausflügler aus
Peking sind außer uns die einzigen hier
ein Museum ohne Besucher
seit den olympischen Wettbewerben ist
hier kein einziger Schlitten
runtergerutscht weil es Bobsport in
China erst gibt seit Peking die Zusage
für die Spiele bekam und weil
Wettbewerbe mit den strengen
corona-regeln nicht möglich waren jetzt
gibt's zum ersten Mal wieder Eis auf der
Bahn kurz nach unserem Besuch soll ein
Training stattfinden
[Musik]
nebenan sind die Pisten der alpinen
Abfahrten ein kleiner Teil davon ist
heute beschneit und für Skifahrer
geöffnet
was viele nicht wissen sie fahren mitten
durch ein Naturschutzgebiet
dessen Grenzen wurden vor Olympia neu
gezogen die Bobbahn und die Abfahrten
wurden einfach rausgeschnitten
und das Naturschutzgebiet ist nicht das
einzige Problem
[Musik]
man sieht da immenseerosion und diese
Erosion die bezieht sich nicht nur auf
die ganz steile hochgelegene Skipisten
sondern auf die ganze Verbindung
Skipisten und auch weiter unterhalb rund
um die Bobbahn die hinterlassen auch
sehr sehr große Narben also sehr große
Auswirkung was jetzt Erosion und
Rutschung angeht
Olympia auf Kosten der Natur wir wollen
wissen wie das olympische Dorf in Gang
der KO heute genutzt wird es war die
größte Unterkunft während der Spiele mit
Platz für 2700 Athletinnen und Athleten
überraschenderweise können wir hier
einfach reinlaufen und filmen
das olympische Dorf hier wurde mitten
ins Nichts gebaut und ein Jahr später
steht das auch mitten im Nichts hier um
uns herum die Häuser sind alle verlassen
es ist niemand da
das war nicht immer so im Sommer nutzte
der chinesische Staat das Dorf um seine
corona-zwangsmaßnahmen durchzusetzen
Pekinger die Kontakt mit einem
corona-fall hatten wurden hierher
gebracht
sie mussten sich mindestens zehn Tage
lang isolieren fast 200 km entfernt von
der Innenstadt
[Musik]
einsam sind wir ab diesem Zeitpunkt
unserer Reise nicht mehr
mehrere Autos verfolgen ab jetzt jeden
unserer Schritte
wir fahren weiter ins Skigebiet schongi
drei Stunden nordwestlich von Peking
diese Nummernschilder sind immer in
Sichtweite
unsere staatlichen Begleiter wollen wir
nicht mit zu unseren Interviewpartnern
bringen zu oft schon haben wir die
Erfahrung gemacht dass jeder der mit uns
spricht danach kontaktiert und bedroht
wird
wenn es nach der chinesischen Führung
geht soll niemand unvorbereitet mit
ausländischen Medien sprechen sie will
kontrollieren was wir berichten
wir hoffen dass wir auf der Skipiste
ungestörte arbeiten können und kommen
mit vielen begeisterten Skifans ins
Gespräch
ich habe Olympia zu Hause geschaut das
Skigebiet war während der Spiele ja
geschlossen
ich liebe schieferen jetzt bringe ich
sie auch dazu
Olympia hat Wintersport in China
gefördert und populär gemacht vorher hat
sich niemand dafür interessiert seit den
Spielen steigt die Zahl der Skifahrer
Skifahren bringt Glücksgefühle aber
natürlich ist der Schnee in Europa
besser
viele schwärmen von ihren skiurlauben in
den Alpen in Neuseeland oder Japan in
den vergangenen drei Jahren war Urlaub
im Ausland wegen der corona-regeln
nahezu unmöglich es blieben nur die
Skigebiete in China
wir fahren hier auf 100% Kunstschnee das
war auch einer der Kritikpunkte bei der
Vergabe Winterspiele an einem der
trockensten Orte der Welt es ist zwar
super kalt aber so trocken dass es
eigentlich keinen natürlichen Schnee
gibt
auch vor Beijing 2022 waren Olympische
Winterspiele nicht nachhaltig diese
waren es allerdings besonders wenig das
Klima ist maximal ungeeignet für
Kunstschnee durch hohe
Windgeschwindigkeiten wird viel
weggeweht die natürliche Vegetation
wurde ersetzt durch alpine Pinienwälder
als Kulisse für das perfekte
Winterwunderland der Hauptkritikpunkt
der extreme Wasserbedarf wenn der Boden
zu trocken ist dann kann der Schnee
nicht auf dem Boden haften deswegen
wurde im Vorfeld erstmal der Boden
benest so dass es überhaupt eine Schicht
gab an auf die der Kunstschnee haften
konnte wenn der Boden zu trocken ist
dann
rutscht der Schnee ab und bleibt gar
nicht liegen ja also das ist etwas dass
man vielleicht bis jetzt noch nie hatte
weil man noch nie in der Art trockenen
Gebieten beschneit hat
ein Vorteil des chinesischen Systems das
Megaprojekt Olympia 2022 wurde von oben
verordnet und wenn der Erfolg verordnet
ist muss er auch eintreten in der
Neujahrsansprache des Präsidenten klingt
das dann so
das heutige china ist ein Land in dem
Träume Wirklichkeit werden die
olympischen und paralympischen
Winterspiele in Peking sind mit einem
überwältigenden Erfolg zu Ende gegangen
die chinesischen Wintersportler haben
ihr bestes gegeben und außergewöhnliche
Ergebnisse erzielt
auch Skilehrer war nicht fidong und
seine Schülerin Mia sind Fans der
chinesischen olympiastars vor allem
natürlich von gualin
mein Einkommen hat sich durch Olympia
erhöht die Leute kennen schieferen jetzt
und lieben es wegen der Spiele unser
Geschäft wird jetzt immer besser mehr
und mehr Leute werden kommen
seit acht Jahren unterrichtet er und
findet es super das ist die
Wettkampfstätten hier jetzt gibt er
träumt von einer erneuten
Olympia-Bewerbung Chinas die
corona-jahre waren hart
Corona hatte wirklich große Auswirkungen
weil die Pisten jederzeit geschlossen
werden konnten aber jetzt ist die
Epidemie endlich vorbei ich bin
glücklich es ist großartig
Corona ist vorbei das ist was die
chinesische Führung verkündet nach der
180 Grad Wende im Dezember hat sie nach
drei Jahren Massentests und
zwangsquarantäne plötzlich alle Regeln
aufgehoben
doch statt besser wurde die Situation in
den Skigebieten zunächst schlechter
weder Gäste noch Personal zu viele
infizierten sich gleichzeitig
in den ersten ein zwei Wochen nach der
Kehrtwende sank die Zahl der Skifahrer
in den meisten Gebieten auf 10 bis 20
Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
hier haben die meisten die
corona-infektionen zwischen gut
überstanden und die Zahlen sind zurück
auf Normalniveau
Mia weiß schon wo sie gerne als nächstes
Skifahren möchte
Italien auf purem Schnee sich ins
Skifahren verlieben bei mir ist der Plan
der olympia-veranstalter aufgegangen
300 Millionen Menschen auf Eis und
Schnee das war das Ziel von Peking bei
der Olympia-Bewerbung ganz schön
unrealistisch für ein Land in dem
Skifahren bis dahin keine große Rolle
gespielt hat und das im großen Teilen
aus Wüste und Subtropen besteht aber
hier erzählen uns viele das Olympia die
wintersportbegeisterung doch vergrößert
hat und sie freuen sich natürlich über
die neuen Anlagen
diese begeisterten kommen auch in den
Laden von schauen Guang er freut sich
vor allem über die Infrastruktur die von
Olympia übrig ist die Autobahn bringt
die Pekinger schneller ins Skigebiet
endlich treffen wir den Kumpel des
anzugkaisers
es kommen wirklich mehr Leute aber unser
Geschäft ist noch nicht auf dem Niveau
von früher
2019 haben wir etwa 20.000 Euro Umsatz
am Tag gemacht also 10.000 mindestens
jetzt sind es gerade mal 5000
seine Kunden sind Leute die es sich
leisten können
schon während seines Studiums jobte er
im Skigebiet doch weil ihm dazu wenig
Zeit blieb um selbst zu fahren macht er
2008 seinen eigenen Laden auf das lief
gut doch jetzt sind seine Ersparnisse
aufgebraucht vor allem wegen Corona auch
Olympia war schwierig während der Spiele
war die ganze Stadt abgeriegelt sein
Shop zu er will jetzt nach vorne schauen
ist vorbei damals lief es nicht so gut
aber die Zukunft wird gut ich bin sicher
dass es gut wird und auch die Wirtschaft
wird sich bald wieder erholen
wenige Meter von seinem Laden entfernt
ist das olympia-museum es ist
geschlossen und das schon seit kurz nach
der Eröffnung nämlich seit die
olympia-wettbewerbe vorbei sind
das Museum steht symbolisch für das was
von Olympia in China übrig bleibt
ungenutzte bauten die verfallen schöne
Fassaden ohne Inhalt eine künstliche
Winterwelt
auf der anderen Seite hat Olympia die
schneebegeisterten weiter motiviert sie
sind stolz auf das was ihr Land und ihre
Medaillengewinner geschafft haben
auf der Rückfahrt nach Peking halten wir
in einem kleinen Dorf neben der
neugebauten Autobahn die Mauern wurden
vor den Spielen mit den Olympia
Maskottchen bemalt inzwischen blättert
die Farbe
Olympia in Sichtweite dabei war von den
Dorfbewohnern niemand
letztes Jahr durften wir nicht zu den
Wettbewerben dieses Jahr will ich wegen
der Pandemie nicht in das Gebiet die
Polizei hat hier letztes Jahr alles
überprüft und lange vor den Spielen
alles dicht gemacht
jetzt würden zwar Touristen zum
Skigebiet fahren aber in seinem Dorf
macht niemand halt ob er Olympia im
Fernsehen geschaut hat
[Musik]
wir normalen Leute gucken das nicht
so was brauchen wir nicht